yeah did you guys see the GTA the new
GTA trailer um velco wanted me to touch
on that yeah it's Miami
VI basically yeah it looks like they
took a lot of the scenery from um news
like news reels and they turn it into
like the uh promo trailer for the game I
played like an old version of GTA back
in the day like an earlier sort of
version It's it sounds like it's a
really popular game now right popular
well I mean they had come out with new
game in 10 years so the the most recent
one is GTA 5 yeah but the reason it's
taken them so long first they were
working on Red Dead Redemption 2 which
is another Rockstar open world game that
won a ton of awards Game of the Year
stuff like that sold a billion copies um
and then but GTA 5 now with online and
and this is what a lot of these video
game companies are doing and this is why
you know gaming is so if that's your
thing like whatever do it but it's it's
much different than it's ever been been
because they have everything's online
there's these microtransactions so they
they kept coming out with new online
content online stories online missions
for GTA 5 and so they were just they
printed more money with the online
component than they ever did with the
hard game uh so there was really no
incentive for there to make a new
version I think the GTA GTA 3 was like
03 GTA
um there was the one that came out every
couple of years a 10year gap is the
biggest in the series by far
and I hear that there's some rumors that
they're G to have a crypto component
what was the controversy with the
trailer I didn't I didn't really get it
I think it might have got leaked not
sure what it was was there a female lead
or something or a trans lead or
something like that yeah there's there
there a
female it's supposedly a Bonnie and
Clyde type of lead with but I think the
main or trans no I think that was a
rumor I don't think I think that's
unsubstantiated I think somebody just
said that on a Reddit or for chant form
or something said that like that but um
I think yeah I just think that again
like the GTA leads have always been male
they've always been about you know it's
just it's another you know Dei
initiative when it comes to one of the
biggest and most testosterone fueled
gaming franchises of all time I think
the best comment sorry the best comment
I saw on it was the Babylon be and it
said San Francisco man is not going to
buy GTA 6 why would he cuz he can commit
crimes without confidence without
consequence in San Francisco anyway yeah
no the last he can just do it in real
life yeah the last time I saw them do
something like this was the follow-up
version of Last of Us and I played the
original Last of Us when it came out
it's actually a really good game um one
the best and they went they sort of like
[__] with that formula and I think they
made the lead um in a either lesbian or
a trans or something like that and there
was a lot of push back from The Gamers
like the hardcore gamer guys and it's
like I didn't even have any interest and
even want to look at it at that point so
it's like you know the woke I don't know
I
mean maybe they'll get it one day but
people pushing back on woke narratives
is costing them money and it's dumb it's
just dumb but I guess it's it's with
everything there's no such thing as a
there's no male spaces anymore right I
mean video games used to be one well
entrepreneur cars.com
Community actually it's closed until
early next year but yeah video games
were always a male thing they were
always for guys it was for guys to just
you know go into their own world and
like we had a a woman on our show this
past ladies night who is now a gamer
she's a streamer and she plays games
with her you know cat ears on and takes
her clothes off when she's not doing
that I mean it's just sign for my only
fans while I'm playing this
[__] but she was Sweet let's not don't
get me wrong but uh yeah it's just
anything that you've Everet though isn't
it like you know like you get into
gaming to play twitch with dudes with
your rabbit ears and your low cut top
and like you know like 70% of your
breast exposed and of course you're
going to have the link to your only fans
of course these guys who are sexist and
not dealing with women and awkward and
anxious playing video games are going to
sign up for it of course of course you
know it's it's newer now but I mean I
remember there was just this like you
just didn't see girls that were in
playing video games especially like
online video games now it's everywhere
but they actually did back in the day
because when World of Warcraft first
first came out like I used to play that
[__] and then you know you would do
these raids with like guilds and there
was always one or two chicks in like one
of these raids and they're yapping away
and it's
like you know at some point there's like
oh well what do you look like some guy
says and you know she links to some to
some social media and she's like a two
you know so now I think like the women
that have some sex appeal and an only
fans have figured out that if they play
video games with a dorks are who can't
get girls they'll they'll build their
subscriber list while they play video
games sort of thing I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the fulllength podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out